hello there guys I hope you're doing
well so we have some big news with
garden and or so Ander will be airing
its first two episodes in the ABC
Network FX Network freeform TV and Hulu
this would be happening on the 23rd of
this month now Disney have never done
this before to any other Star Wars
project on Disney plus this is a first
and this could mean one of two things
the show is such good quality that they
want to expand its audience and show to
other people or that the show is
actually underperforming and they feel
like this is the only way they can get
the show out there to other audiences
and increase the viewership which I hope
it's not the second one because that
would be unfortunate because I do have
to say I think Andor is probably one of
the best if not the best Star Wars live
action TV show at least in my opinion I
think it's just made super well although
one thing which I feel like I made a
mistake on is that they're only arrow in
the first two episodes they should have
definitely started with the first three
episodes because I feel like you watched
the first two episodes and you just
missing a piece of the puzzle zoo and it
doesn't make you really want to watch
the next episode because in my opinion
the second episode is probably my least
favorite one out of the whole entire
show so far but once you finish that
third episode you're like man this show
is really good I just want to watch the
next episode and see what happens but
after the second episode you don't get
that hyping you don't get that Intrigue
or that don't get the sense of wanting
to know what happens next and watching
the episodes after that so I feel like
they should have definitely aired the
first three episodes because that
completes the first story arc for the
show whereas the first two is just an
incomplete puzzle but anyway that's
about it for this video so what are you
guys think and if you did enjoy this
video please consider subscribing thanks
for watching guys